we're following a deadly stabbing in
summerlin this afternoon that happened
near town center in hualapai that's
where we find hector mejia with the very
latest on this story hector what do we
know so far
hey there well no word yet about any
arrests but right now more investigators
arriving to the scene metro police
cruisers here blocking streets while
they try to figure out who stabbed
someone to death at one of these homes
meanwhile banbury cross drive and other
neighborhood streets are closed right
now the call we're told came in just
before 10 a.m a short time ago we saw
metro's helicopter circling above here
near town center in hualapai this is a
residential area for some perspective
the home is located just a few blocks
north of summerlin hospital
officers have not announced what may
have led to the stabbing or if they have
anyone in custody and we are expecting
to learn more about what happened here
in a briefing we're getting from
homicide detectives at one o'clock in
the afternoon and since the hospital is
so close in case you're wondering police
are not blocking any entrances into the
hospital reporting live in summerlin
hector mejia 8 news now